brand new television show brought to you
by the creators of Stargate that's right
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
before we get into this video I want to
talk to you about nine chevrons.com my
answer everyone's is your source for
Stargate news featuring news articles
reviews and more there's also a
dedicated community so you can join
like-minded Stargate fans and make your
voice heard
so stay up to date join the community
and join us on ninechevrons.com
Stargate fans have a lot to look forward
to this year one thing in particular I'm
looking forward to is the release of the
arc it's been created by Dean Devlin the
co-producer of the original Stargate
movie in 1994 and Jonathan Glassner and
it actually looks really good on screen
now you'll be able to see the trailer
that is playing for the arc and I'm
going to leave a link in the description
so you can actually watch this trailer
in full but this is a TV show that looks
and feels very much like how Stargate
Universe probably should have been I've
said it before Stargate Universe was way
ahead of its time it came off the back
of Stargate sg1 Stargate Atlantis and it
just wasn't received as well as it maybe
should have been when it first came out
it was a lot darker it was a lot
grittier and it was one cohesive story
rather than the episodic format that
we've been used to Starlight Universe
was definitely ahead of its time at
least in my opinion and I've said this
so many times on this channel the ark is
very very similar at least in premise
because it looks like it's going to be a
TV show centered around a spaceship that
the crew are not actually meant to be in
that's not entirely true actually the
arc looks like it's a colony ship sent
out so they can colonize a different
planet and it's made up mainly of like
the best engineers and the best
scientists that the Earth has to offer
and they've sent them out to colonize a
new planet but something happens which
means they're no longer on course they
have to stop the ship and they have to
survive in the situation they're in so
it's kind of like Stargate Universe but
it's kind of its own thing at the same
time
now obviously it's not trying to be
Stargate it's not trying to be the what
Stargate Universe wanted to be it is its
own show but I'm just drawing
comparisons because we talk about
Stargate a lot and it's one of those
television shows that if something else
comes out I know like personally if it's
a science fiction show I'm going to
compare it to Starkey is it as good as
my favorite television show the fact
that this show has been created by Dean
Devlin the guy who actually co-wrote the
original Stargate movie in 1994 and
Jonathan Glassner who worked on Stargate
sg1 it gives me so much hope for this
this show
two people who have worked on the the
best franchise I've ever watched in my
entire life are going to be making this
show or they've already made it it's
already coming out it's coming out in
about two weeks
I've got so so much hope for it see I
love science fiction where it's kind of
grounded in reality and this looks like
it might just be that
it's set in the not too distant future
maybe a couple of hundred years perhaps
and we've sent out a colony ship we're
gonna we're gonna colonize another
planet and something goes wrong during
that mission and you have to fight to
survive and that's the kind of Science
Fiction I like people putting in a
possible situation how do they adapt
that situation and how do they
survive that's the entire reason I love
Stargate Universe it was very different
to sg1 in Atlantis but in such a good
way there are a lot of people who didn't
like Stargate Universe and that's
completely understandable
but I would say
give the arc a chance because it might
actually be that television show it
might just be
the next big thing it might be it might
not be we don't know we've not seen it
but it looks
like it has a really good concept and it
looks like it might actually be good the
show is going to be premiering on the
Sci-Fi channel and it's going to come
out on February 1st 2023. as I said
before I'm going to leave a link in the
description to the trailer for The Arc
go and watch it
come back to this video after you've
watched it and tell me what you think do
you are you excited for this television
show do you think it uh do you think the
parallels that I've drawn from SGU
and the art ring true to you or am I
just talking a load of waffle are you
excited for this television show that's
something that I really want to know
because when it comes out I'm gonna very
very likely be reviewing the first
episode so my excitement right now for
it might change when the first episode
comes out because it might end up being
like
really really crap and no one likes it
and it's actually awful but at the
minute I'm looking at it and I'm really
hopeful because it's created by the guys
who created Stargate or at least
you know the the two portions of it
you've got the movie and then you've got
sg1
so they've created or helped create the
franchise that we know and love so this
could be this could be the thing this
could be the thing I don't know let me
know in the comment section down below
what you think and whilst you're down
there hit subscribe and press the Bell
notification so you don't miss a single
video also consider becoming a fully
flat side tracker by hitting the join
button down below thank you so much for
watching and I will see you
next week
foreign
[Music]